je suis l'enfant de la guerre je suis né
dedans
les gens croient comprendre la douleur
ils savent même pas ce que c'est tapirs
douleur à toi c'est quoi ce serait
peut-être celle qui fait de toi une
machine plutôt qu'un homme après non
stop
mais c'est quoi ça gbagbo pourquoi il
manque les effets spéciaux son bras il
est censé être métal c'est pas comme
s'il suffisait dépasser une moustache
je vais faire moi même je suis diable je
viens que futur et je suis toujours
vénère non pas le shérif d'être pour eux
tu sais tu étais beaucoup plus grand
dans la lah terme se croient que dieu
vient s'accrocher au pouvoir de
régénération active et samedi place à
fait remarquable groupe est en fonte à
ton service
on ne mord pas
déjà prêt à bas ce fut rapide bon une
fois très bien envoyé
[Musique]
c'est fini pour tous appelés au là c'est
le dialoguiste qui s'est pas foulée